chinese journalist
who documented wuhan coronavirus
outbreak jail for four years
zhang jhan 37 years old was found guilty
of picking corals and provoking trouble
according to one of
her defense lawyers jan kiki who
attended her hearing the offenses
commonly used by the chinese government
to target dissidents
and human rights activists a former
lawyer zhang traveled
some 400 miles from shanghai to one in
early february to report on the pandemic
and subsequent attempt to contain it
just as authorities began reigning in
state and private chinese media for more
than three months she documented
snippets of her life
under lockdown and wuhan and the harsh
reality faced by the residents
from overflowing hospitals to empty
shops she posted her observations photos
on video on which
wechat twitter and youtube the latter
two of which are blocked in china and
she's now going to jail
for four years thoughts scary i mean my
god
i don't know uh four years what she did
you know it's not like she was writing
editorials every day railing against the
president or railing against communism
she was basically
documenting life in china during the
pandemic
and then you know the thing that just is
crazy about this is these charges i mean
it almost seems
like too bizarre like you couldn't even
make it up quarreling you know things
like that
they can literally almost invent a
charge to suppress people
to lock them up to show that they're in
charge here
uh she's one of at least 47 journalists
that are in detention in china right now
so it's not like she's the only one
and you know what they get these people
and they're forgotten i mean who knows
what they're doing to them behind the
scenes before they even put him in
prison
so it's pretty scary um you know that
they can control
every bit of information that's said
about it and just
i think the other interesting thing is
to watch how the american media treats
this story
like if they're not appalled by it
there's something wrong
well i think the us media is is going to
la it's going to talk about this but
then kind of give it a little bit of a
pass
because the corporate tentacles go all
the way
from here to china let's face it
there's another word for china it's
called factory
and if you want to change the cost
structure of everything you buy
from this pen to the iphone to the seats
in your car
get ready so a whole economic case study
i could drop into there but this does
not surprise me
china this is you don't
you don't disagree with big poppy that's
it
and and it's not surprising and i think
you're like oh you
got very strong opinions today you got
to hold back a little bit with your
opinions you you go you're on a little
too strong today and i think you're
offending people
you know i would like you to taper down
a little bit and not upset the folks of
china because
they may come after you so you know i
don't know if you guys are getting to my
drift you know it's a little too much
tom you're offending my friends of china
okay and if you piss them off they will
come and they will find you
similar to the line from the girl in
wedding crashes i will find you
okay if you remember that scene i don't
know if you could probably i didn't
because that did that that's right she's
a beast by the way
i did i didn't see uh wedding crashers
no i mean it's a very it's a highly
recommended by
christian.com website
there might be a pg version of it out
there somewhere yeah it's
13 minutes long edited it's the credits
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye